c'est lui françois asselineau cet ancien
conseiller de paris fondateur du parti
union populaire républicaine souhaite se
présenter à l'élection présidentielle
il tenait une conférence jeudi dernier à
saint germain en laye pour faire
entendre ses idées souverainistes le
même sort pour dire expliquer comment ça
fait que 25 ans on a vu ça serait
l'endroit en point alors que c'est le
désastre courbes et graphiques à l'appui
cet énarque de 59 ans passé également
par hec défend le fch exit inspiré du
breakbeat le concept reviendrait en
pratique à sortir de l'europe pour
retrouver de la marge de manoeuvre
budgétaire
nous proposons d'en sortir pour redonner
aux français et bien leurs moyens de
décider de leur avenir collectif
la france n'est plus dirigé par les
français elle est dirigée par des
institutions internationales dans
lesquelles les français n'ont plus leur
mot à dire qui s'appelle la commission
européenne à bruxelles
la banque centrale européenne à
francfort et puis l'otan dont le siège
est à bruxelles mais qu'il est jugé
depuis washington
un temps membre de l'ump françois
asselineau a flirté avec d'autres partis
avant de créer l'upm en 2007 associé à
l'ultra droite
il réfute cependant toute similitude
entre ces idées et celles du front
national
mais adhérents aux thèses
conspirationnistes
il soutient notamment que la montée de
l'état islamique serait l'oeuvre de la
cia
pour le moment ces réunions attire
surtout des curieux j'étais très
perplexe sur 7 sur cette prise de
position du fric site
mais c'est vrai que
je me pose beaucoup de questions
françois asselineau part donc en quête
des 500 fameux parrainage en 2012 il
avait déjà tenté de se présenter mais
sans succès seuls 17 élus lui avaient
apporté leur soutien